but i want to read something to the
truth that's concerning because
we're playing a little bit of the
slippery slope with the the trans uh
side right and so this story comes at
california trans child molester
hannah tubbs gloats over light sentence
and jailhouse phone calls okay
explicit los angeles jailhouse
recordings of hannah tubbs a 26-year-old
trans child molester who received a slap
on a wrist
in january after pleading guilty to
molesting a 10 year old in 2014 the
picture admitting it was wrong to attack
a little girl but gloating over the
light punishment tubbs pleaded guilty
last month to
the cold case attack which took place in
the women's restroom at denny's
restaurant when the suspect who was two
weeks shy of 18
and identified as a male named james
tubbs after being arrested roughly
eight years after the crime tubbs began
identifying as a woman she received a
sentence of two years at a juvenile
facility because democrat district
attorney george
okay so
how how concerned are you with what's
happening today with
the trans side where laws are almost
protecting against i think somebody even
had a
did somebody have a sex change to
prevent from having a long sentence this
was a two months ago story do you
remember that one story where somebody
did this
how much of a slippery slope are we
dealing with when it comes down to the
to this uh i think if you take this case
and isolate it i think the more
the question is
you know did this person i mean take the
trans out of it for a minute there was a
sexual assault of a minor
but they didn't catch the person until
they were older
so at the time of the crime
what was the age difference
now gloating about getting away with it
is horrible and wrong
and and that person probably deserved a
higher sentence i'm not so sure that in
this case
being trans had anything to do
with the sentence i think it had more to
do with the age
of the person when the crime was
committed and i know that there
there have been
a lot of criticisms of this particular
district attorney out there and i know
people who work in that office who think
that you know he's too light on some of
these crimes and they don't go after
some of the stuff aggressively enough
but i think in this case the trans issue
gets a headline because
of what it is but the real matter of the
case is that somebody got away with a
light sentence whether they're trans or
not
yeah you see so you know the the the
topic about
you know the pizza guy okay with the
pieces like well it was consent yeah
what do you mean you can't
conservatively what are you talking
about right now this is a guy he had a
marriage contract this guy was a bad guy
right and i've gone back to some of
these guys 44 years old at the time yeah
jeff sokol and i went back to him to
reach out as i do with many of these
guys to get them to see if they'll talk
to me on the podcast because i think it
would be
interesting and i've been in discussions
with some of them who
i think may do it jeff said yes jeff
said no okay i'm not surprised but yeah
here is so so maybe you've brought some
awesome pizza yeah they planted pizza
from the part the part about the
slippery slope is
you know
the law today states what at what age
uh uh if you have sex with a minor it's
what 18 it's under 18. depending on the
state okay it's different but it can be
it's usually 18
unless both parties are under
18. so in other words if
if a 15 year old girl has sex with a 16
year old boy in a lot of states that's
not illegal
right because the the age of its
influence i mean in some states it is
illegal
in some states it may be i don't know
the law in every state but i know that
in many states if both parties are
within a year of each other and under
age it's not illegal
if one party is 30 and one is 15 then
that's illegal right and then the gray
area comes when somebody as you
mentioned earlier somebody's 16
somebody's 19 is that inappropriate i
can tell you
that during our investigations
the profile of the the
the target is
at the oldest 14 because it takes that
gray area out of it so in other words
if it's a 19 year old and a 13 14 13 or
12 year old child
you can say well he's only 19. but then
i would argue that okay what's the
difference between a 19 year old
violating a 12 year old and a 38 year
old what's the difference i brought this
up to to a guy i was speaking to
uh about the
19 year old and the 15 year old and i
said what do you think about that well
you know that's that's not cool
uh you shouldn't be doing that i said
okay how about a 60 year old dating a 20
year old
mm-hmm
what do you think 16 years i think i
think a 20 year old is of legal age in
terms of consent so
you know it may look creepy but it's not
illegal yeah
so so the the the law for me that i'm
going to with trans is the following
they're trying to pass
you following the story that they're
trying to
allow a minor to make a decision to have
a sex change how does that and they're
talking about the same seattle in
seattle the miner doesn't even have to
get the parent's permission and it's
against the law for the physician to
tell the parent that the minor wants a
sex change right this is happening in a
lot of places across the country
well i think you know you get into a
really complicated area here because
and i'm not expert in it by any stretch
of the imagination but i do you know
read up on it because
you know it's interesting
um
there are cases where
somebody at a young age thinks they want
to have
gender reassignment surgery
and then has regrets afterwards now how
do you put that back together once it's
happened so
just like in a lot of other areas you
know
there's mandatory counseling before you
take certain steps
and it would seem this is one of them
and again you know this is all new so
we're all making this up as we go along
we don't know
but there is there is information out
there that suggests that in a certain
number of cases people feel that they
want to do this and then they have
regrets and second thoughts and they
want to reverse it and that's difficult
if not impossible washington laws
now allow teen gender reassignment
surgery without parental consent
that's just weird to me
you tell me how that makes any sense
what comes after that
you know what comes after that to say
what's wrong with a 22 year old dating a
13 year old i mean i'm from iran in iran
the age used to be a 50 year old man
could marry a 13 year old girl and when
the shah got elected i think you raised
it to 15 maybe 18 it's back down to 13
today by the way today a 50 year old man
can marry 13 i think
it's 13 years old right now and it's
normal there
what if now you know stories like this
end up passing on people oh you gotta
let's their choice it's their choice and
people say i think 18's is too old i
think we gotta lower that to 15.
should we fight that
it's a law right
should we say okay what if there comes a
time when they change the law from 18 to
15. and half the country agrees and they
say what's wrong with that
what what are we doing now now people
can't say well that's just the law now
we have to follow that law
well i think sometimes common sense
loses out and i think we have to
find this middle ground you know we get
so polarized in so many aspects of
politics and
everything else that we're going through
today you know you get to the covet
thing i mean yes there's a great story
there and i'm talking to a lot of people
about that is it hard to get to china
yes is it hard to get the truth out of
china absolutely i've been there i've
done stories there
but
we do lose common sense sometimes and i
think this is an area i mean i don't
think a 13 year old
should be able to decide
on their own surgery no matter what the
surgery we're on the same stage and i
think parents have to be civilians are
on the same page i can i can tell you
this and this is the only thing in this
whole area that i can tell you for sure
is
that when you have a potential
transgender issue in your family
the rate of suicide is dramatically
lower when a family is open and
accepting and has a discussion
that i can tell you that i know for a
fact
other than that
you know we're making new
new decisions in in an area that we
haven't dealt with before how much do we
have transgenderism in the 20s
so go to 20s and 30s
what was transgenderism in the 20s and
30s like this whole thing to say if it's
accepted by parents
it didn't didn't didn't we just read an
article that said the number one step to
uh
you know somebody abusing your kid the
first step is to win the trust of who
the parents i mean that's the same
argument as saying chris i may be wrong
is to say
let's first get the parents to accept
the concept of
their kids wanting to go through it
and then once we win the parents over
and then we can get the kids but we
first have to get the parents to think
that it's normal
because i don't i don't know if you know
this topic was a topic and i'd love to
get more of the history of it on when it
started you know i'd love to see
uh in the 30s was it a normal thing was
it normal to talk about these types of
surgeries i mean i know it's been around
for a while but
i want to know the
the
what's the word i want to know the
history
not only the history of it you know
again from an investigative journalistic
standpoint like i want to know the
out of a thousand people that did the
surgery i want to know the profile i
want to know the parenting i want to
know at what age i want to know
you know
siblings do they have an older sister
older brother what's the relationship
with the older brother sister was there
an abusive uncle or person i want i want
to investigate that i want to know that
but we're so afraid to investigate that
all we're investigating is well parents
should be more acceptable about this
this this and that and i think
rather than doing that we're not putting
the time into the real conversation
which is
you know suicide in the military why
does susan and military happen what is
it
what causes suicide in the military to
happen
you know is it
away from the family did some people
join the military to get away from the
family are they running away from family
you mean to tell me everybody that joins
the army is that patriotic i have a hard
time believing it when i was in the
military i had a lot of guys that were
in the military they were not in there
because they were patriotic there were
people that were in the military that
actually didn't like the country they
were just people in the military for gi
bill some were there because they
couldn't stand their dad they wanted to
get away
and we had stories of uh uh what do you
call it the suicide and it's
heartbreaking you know i had one of my
uh close
friends from you know military that went
through it and i saw his relationship
with his father
his father would slap him in the face in
front of us and i'm like i can't i can't
even be around it his father was so
abusive to him in front of all of us
and he would be so embarrassed when he
was around us so
he never felt like he could do anything
to please his dad and eventually took
his life was that the reason so
education is what it comes down to is
where i'm going and awareness in a
dialogue that's all i want to know i
like when you said you said something
about james o'keefe you said that's an
opinion
and then he said oliver stone is an
opinion right that's an opinion well
the opinion is on both sides right sure
absolutely you said you want to get to
what was the word you used not the truth
you said you wanted to uh you given
which i agree with you want to find out
the why let's just say right the
original
i want to know you know there's a lot of
questions i got i want to know do we
really make the right choice going to
war in iraq you know and we're like oh
that weapon is a mass destruction guess
what what was that exist what was this
whole thing with the way we handled
afghanistan that was catastrophic we
just lost 80 billion dollars this whole
thing going on with russia and ukraine
right now what is the real motive does
america is america using ukraine as a
proxy to get rid of putin we don't know
i want to know i'm curious right i'm
curious to know
what some of the some of these things
are historically
you haven't been in this space for a
while who's who was the name of people
that would go investigate the heavy duty
topics that would come and give the most
uh
fair assessment from both sides i mean
cronkite was more of a
personality guy who was like the
investigative journalist that would give
both sides of the story
yeah i think i think the 60 minutes guys
obviously in
mike wallace sure
uh our friend john stossel stossel did a
lot of great work over the years
um
in a whole combination walt bogdanovich
you know at the new york times and other
places
and the whole teams of
print reporters who would go after this
chicago tribune
going back to you know the the meat
packing uh industry uh you know upped in
sinclair and you know
talking about all that
the chicago papers did a great thing
where they opened up a bar
and they
saw everybody hit them up for bribes the
inspectors and the contractors it was
but it was it was seminole we once had a
story put together
where we had some guys come in and we
were going to open up a gentleman's club
a strip club
and watch
the people come in in new york city we
had a location and everything from the
mob supplying the dancers to the people
inspecting the place to do the whole
thing and then put hidden cameras in and
capture the whole thing and the lawyers
ended up nixing it because there
admittedly a lot of
issues doing that
you know how long do you run it but the
interesting thing was that the guys were
consulting with me on it
said that they could pay for the entire
project with the proceeds of actually
having a club in queens
and it got pretty high up and then you
see right now we're going to open this
room we had a name for you the whole
thing didn't happen but it didn't have
well and and i understand why i mean
the legal questions were
just overwhelming and strangling of
doing something no question but i mean
and then
you know you're operating this thing and
you've got legitimate people working
there
people going there as customers do you
you know what do you do
yeah why are the places with hidden
cameras
and that's constitutionally
iffy i mean it'd be great television
but i mean the lord
and the best part was in the pitch
meeting i said and it pays for itself
you know because we'd raise it was going
to be 400 grand to do it
and i think we're going to make back 400
grand in the first year and we actually
had
former federal local law enforcement
people who were going to consult on this
who had done this for other
investigations and it was i thought it
was genius but i understood at the end
of the day what the why it was 400 grant
to do it and you're going to get 400
grand back i mean that would be
perfect tv right
yeah but then you know you got a guy who
goes into a club like that for one night
and he gets captured on a hidden camera
you know what do you do with that yeah
and you got a woman who's working in
that business because she's trying to
feed her kids
what do you do with that at what point
does it become exploitive
versus interesting notwithstanding
all the other legal issues if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]